I'm not broken I'm just different you
could have a diagnosis I got mine at 28
but I was really I always knew I was a
slightly different what made you get
that then I just thought tell me God
tell me tell me what I already know
right validate me I need to be validated
because it's loads of money it's like
1500 quids to have it tell me there's
something different about me and then I
can understand it and I thought it would
help me understand it no no so I got
diagnosed and I had nothing changed next
day I carried on exactly the same there
were points when I get out of a meeting
I need to I need to run around the room
right I need to get busy and I can't
think before I speak I will get myself
in trouble because I just exude passion
and energy and I just throw myself into
things and I need to explain that
sometimes you say listen I've got ADHD I
actually occasionally can't help it when
I get out of this room I'm gonna need to
run around I'm gonna need to like Sprint
right I'm gonna have to do some stuff to
burn off this additional energy and it
comes out in moving shaking and such a
weird thing but what a superpower for a
salesperson or a recruiter I could not
handle the volume or the pressure all
the plates I have to spin which is the
best recruitment analogy to describe I'm
doing this all day without ADHD so I I
absolutely credit a lot of My Success to
being capable of handling what people
without ADHD or people without that
level can do but we've probably all got
something a bit different about us and
it's how we harness these superpowers
and turn them into stuff for us and yeah
I don't like some of the negatives like
the overthinking the worrying the not
being able to sleep at some nights and
like all the bad bits of ADHD I dislike
that stuff but I wouldn't trade losing
all the skills and the superpowers I
generate from it to get rid of some of
the bad stuffs I just have to apologize
more often the recruitment mentors
podcast is proudly sponsored by VIN
cherry and the award-winning Source
breaker
[Music]